for HR+/HER2- MBC.
>> WELL, A SIXTH BOMB BLAST
APPEARS TO HAVE JUST ROCKED
AUSTIN, TEXAS INJURING AT LEAST
ONE PERSON.
POLICE ARE INVESTIGATING ANOTHER
PACKAGE.
THEY SAY IT'S SUSPICIOUS AND
COULD BE AN EXPLOSIVE.
THEY DON'T KNOW YET.
CASEY STEGALL IS IN AUSTIN
COVERING THE MAN HUNT FOR THE
BOMBER AND JOINS US WITH THE
LATEST.
CASEY?
>> YEAH, TUCKER.
UNBELIEVABLE.
WE GOT OFF THE AIR WITH YOU AT
THE TOP OF THE HOUR.
NOW HERE WE ARE IN A DIFFERENT
SPOT.
A SIXTH BOMB HAS GONE OFF IN
AUSTIN.
IT'S IN SOUTH AUSTIN THIS TIME.
WE ARE AT THE INTERSECTION OF
BRODY LANE AND SLAUGHTER LANE.
THIS IS CLOSE TO THE BOMB SITE
ON SUNDAY.
WE'RE ONLY ABOUT SIX MILES AWAY.
THE ONE THAT HAD THE TRIP WIRE
ON IT.
A POLICE HEAVY ACTIVITY IN THE
AREA RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE US PUSH BACK FAR BECAUSE
IT'S A FLUID AND DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
THEY WANT TO KEEP EVERYONE
INCLUDING PUBLIC WHO IS
GATHERING TO TAKE PICTURES AND
SEE THIS FOR THEMSELVES.
THEY WANT TO KEEP THEM SAFE.
WE KNOW IT WAS AT A GOODWILL.
WHETHER IT WAS INSIDE, OUTSIDE,
THAT'S UNCLEAR AT THIS POINT.
WE KNOW IT WAS A GOODWILL.
WHEN THE DISPATCH CALL WENT OUT,
WE MATCHED THE ADDRESS.
AND MY PRODUCER CONTACTED
GOODWILL LOCALLY AND SHE WAS
UPSET.
ONE PERSON IS INJURED.
IT'S NOT LIFE THREATENING.
THAT'S THE LATEST AS POLICE ARE
DEALING WITH A SIXTH BOMBING